مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعنوي
ملك الاردن يعبر عن ثقته بنجاح قمه جده
ويصف النهضه السعوديه الحاليه بالملهمه
لدول المنطقه
هل هذه الحمله وتوجيهها ودعم كل الاجهزه
الامنيه
وزير الداخليه السعوديه واكدوا الدعم
الكامل لمنسوبي مكافحه المخدرات الحمله
الحاليه لا تزال في بدايتها
بدو تنظيمات الحج منع المقيمين من دخول
مكه دون تصريح او هويه مصدرها العاصمه
المقدسه
في الرابعه ايضا
[موسيقى]
عبد الله القويس دبلوماسيه ومصرفيه سعودي
سابق يصل قمه بعد تجاوزه 84 عاما
[موسيقى]
والموت يغيب الفنان الكوميدي السعودي فهد
الحيان عن 52 عاما طاش ما طاش ابرز محطته
الفنيه
قبل ايام من القمه العربيه المنتظره في
جده اعرب العاهل الاردني الملك عبد الله
الثاني في تصريحات لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط عن
ثقته بنجاح القمه وعبر الملك عبد الله
الثاني عن ثقته بالجهود التي يبذلها ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان التي
وفرت اعدادا جيدا يضمن نجاح القمه مشيرا
الى وجود قناعه بضروره ارساء العلاقات
العربيه العربيه على اسس صلب من التعاون
الاقتصادي وتحصينها من التباينات السياسيه
العاهل الاردني وصف النهضه الحاليه التي
تعيشها السعوديه بانها تجربه ملهمه لدول
المنطقه وان كل عربي يشعر بالفخر حيال
جهود الاصلاح والتطوير كما عبر الملك عبد
الله الثاني عن امنياته بان تكون الدول
العربيه امام فرصه جديده يمكن فيها حشد
الطاقات لفتح افاق الازدهار والاستقرار
لما فيه مصلحه الشعوب العربيه على حد قوله
[موسيقى]
انضم الينا في استديوهاتنا من الرياضه
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي والاقتصادي
سجاد حياك الله اهلا وسهلا حياك الله
المتابع اليوم
للايام التي تسبق عقد قمه جده يرى ان هناك
تحضيرات مختلفه اعداد ربما لقاء التجري
قرارات ايضا سياق سياسي ربما يجعلنا نصل
الى انو او نعتقد بان هناك تغيرات في
قواعد اللعبه هي التي تقود الان الى قمه
جدا لكن السؤال ما الذي تريده السعوديه
اليوم من وراء كل هذه التحضيرات
والترتيبات التي تسبق عن عقد هذه القمه في
هذا التوقيت
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم نعتقد ان العالم
ككل والمنطقه بشكل خاص تمر بتغيرات كبيره
جدا يحتاج الان العالم العربي لقياده
لتصحيح الاوضاع وترتيب الفوضى التي كانت
موجوده في المنطقه منذ عشرين سنه منذ
الغزو الامريكي للعراق مرر العالم العربي
بعده تغيرات سواء كان على المستوى السياسي
او حتى الاقتصادي او الشعبي الثورات
العربيه الخلافات الثنائيه ما بين دول
المنطقه افرزت لنا منطقه خليني اسميها
فوضويه حان الوقت بان تستلم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه قيادتها بشكل مباشر
وتقوده الى الى بر الامان الان نحن في
مرحله مفصليه عالميا المنطقه بشكل خاص
تحتاج الى هذا النوع من ترتيب الاوراق
وبالطبع بحكم مكانه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وقدرتها على القياده في هذا
التوقيت تسعى لان تكون
القمه العربيه القادمه قمه فاصله وفارقه
في
فارق يجب ان يتم الان العالم العربي مر
بعده مراحل سواء كنا نتحدث ما قبل وهي
مطرح الا فاصله ما قبل الثورات العربيه او
ما بعد الثورات العربيه
الحكومات والشعوب الامزجه الوضع الاقتصادي
ما بعد
كورونا الان العالم كله يمر متغيرات
والحلقه الاضعف ربما في هذا التوقيت هي
عندنا دول عربيه تمر في فوضى عندنا اكثر
من الدول العربيه تمر في فوضى عاريه اكثر
لو اخذناها اكثر من نصف الدول العربيه
ايضا تمر في ازمات اقتصاديه خانقه المزاج
العربي يجب ان يتغير يتغير الى التكامل
والتعاون وليس كما كان يتحدث سابقا عن
الوحده والعروبيه والقوميه التي كانت تقود
المنطقه بشكل عاطفي اكثر مما هو شكل منطقي
كيف تنهض المنطقه وانت لديك دوله قريبه
منك تعيش في فوضى والدوله الاخرى تعيش في
ازمه اقتصاديه والاخرى لديها مناكفات
سياسيه الان يجب ان ينتهي هذا المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تقود هذه النهضه وترى ان
الفرصه مواتيه جدا
في القمه العربيه القادمه لان تحدث تغييره
بكل تاكيد النهج السعودي الان تغير تغيرا
جذريا بانه اصبحت لا نريد الاجتماع لمجرد
الاجتماع لا نريد القمه لمجرد اخذ صورتي
الان يجب التحرك لان يكون هناك يعني مثلا
يبقى خلينا نقول انه اهم منجز يمكن تحقق
في سياسه التصوير المشاكل الذي يتحدث عنه
الكثير من المراقبين هي مساله الاتفاق
السعودي معي بعد ذلك ما عقبه من عوده
سوريا الى جامعه الدول العربيه توجيه دعوه
ربما كذلك الى رئيس السوري لحضور هذه
القمه مرت المنطقه باجواء تشعر فيها انها
هادئه يعني بعد ذلك اشتغلت في السودان
السودان ربما تعتبر حاله خاصه
تحتاج الى تفاصيل طويل ولكن الاتفاق
السعودي الايراني هذا لم ياتي من فرق
سنتين من المباحثات والمداولات وهو ليس
اتفاقا كاملا يعني حتى حتى في التصريح في
البيان الختامي هو الاتفاق على ايجاد حل
وجود ارضيه مشتركه تحديد المشاكل التعاون
في ايجاد حل هذه المشاكل وانا اعتقد ان
هذا النموذج يجب ان يطبق حتى في الدول
العربيه الاخرى هناك دول كثيره في عندها
خلافات ثنائيه ما بين هذه الدول ايضا
القناعه الكامله على يجب ان تصفر هذه
المشاكل لتجد ان لتجد الحلول لدينا الان
اكبر او اضخم مشروع تنمويه ربما في تاريخ
المنطقه رؤيه 2030 هذه الرؤيه ايضا تحتاج
الى ان تكون منطقه هادئه الامنك القومي
عمقك الاستراتيجي يبدا وليس من الدوله
المجاوره لك بل من الدوله التي تليها فما
بالك لما تكون هذه الدول لديها دين مشترك
لغه مشتركه عراق مشتركه كل عيدولوجيه
مشتركه من ذلك من المعيب ان تبقى هذه
الدول كل هذه السنوات والغريب حقيقه ان
تبقى هذه الدول كلها هذه السنوات وهي فعلا
اختلاف الان ربما الدول العربيه وجدت على
راسها المملكه العربيه السعوديه وجدت انه
الحل المشاكل العربيه يتم من خلال العرب
وليس من خلال الدول او القوى الكبرى التي
تتدخل
استطاع العرب ان يحلوا مشاكله
في جامعاتهم وفي قممهم يعني بدون مؤثرات
وبالتالي اليوم هل الوضع متغير هل يمكن
الاستفاده من الظرف لان بالفعل يدخل
الاقتصاد كقائد لقاطره عمل عربي في قمه
عربيه مختلفه في جده وين
سقف او درجه
تتوخها السعوديه وتقول بانها
القمامه التي انتجت بيانات كلام دون افعال
ركوب القطار ينطلق للتصحيح وللاصلاح يجب
على الدول الان ان تتعاون مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ركوب هذا القطار نحن لا
نريد يعني القمه لن تخرج بحلول سحريه بين
يوم وليله ويكون كل شيء ورديا يعني يجب ان
يكون هناك ارضيه مشتركه اتفاق هل فعلا من
سياتي للقمه يكون يرغب فعلا بالحل ام
ستستمر المناكفات وبيان ختامى لا يخرج الا
بعد شد وجذب يعني خليني اسميه
مجرد يعني ارضاء لاطراف اخرى ومجرد لكي
تخرج الصوره الجماعيه في الختام
بصوره جيده الان لم تدعو المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بهذا التوقيت الجامعه العربيه
وهذا الاهتمام الا انها تريد ان تضع حجر
الاساس نحن نريد ان نتكلم عن مملكه تضع
حجر الاساس وتاسس وتضع لبنه العمل العربي
المشتركي يعاد احياء بصيغه جديده صيغه
المصالح المشتركه صيغه ان النهوض يجب ان
يكون سويا الامير محمد بن سلمان قال في
عده مناسبات رؤيه 2030 هي رؤيه تكامليه
يجب ان تنهض المنطقه ككل يجب ان ننهض
جميعا حتى في مسمى لما سماها اوروبا
الجديده هذا ايضا لان هناك نظره شموليه
الان هناك قاطره تنطلق من يريد ان يكون
مرنا ويتنازل عن بعض قناعاته ويركب هذه
حياه الله اللي ما يركب هذه القاطره الان
سوف يدفع ثمنا مضاعفا لاحقا يفوت القطار
بان اراد ادراكه سوف يدفع ثمن مضاعف
ليدرك هذا القطار هل هل الشعوب استوعبت هل
القيادات استوعبت هل الرغبات الان اصبحت
رغبات نهضويه اكثر ما هي واقعيه اكثر منها
شعبويه نتمنى ذلك حقيقه شكرا العبيد
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي والاقتصادي
دانت وزاره الخارجات السعوديه اقتحام
السفاره الاردن في السودان ومقر سكن رئيس
المكتب العسكري في السفاره الكويت في
الخرطوم وعربت الخارجات السعوديه عن رفض
المملكه التام لكل اشكال العنف والتخريب
تجاه البعثات والممثليات الدبلوماسيه
وطالبت الاطراف السودانيه كافه الالتزام
بالتهدئه وفي نتائج مباحثات جدا الاخيره
والانخراط في المسارات السياسيه التي تسعى
للوصول الى حل معادل وشامل للازمه
السودانيه
اكد وزار وزير الداخليه السعوديه الامير
عبد العزيز بن سعود بن نايف ان منسوبي
مكافحه المخدرات يحضون بدعم كامل من
الامير محمد بن سلمان مشيرا الى ان الحمله
الحاليه لمكافحه المخدرات مستمره حتى
تحقيق كل اهدافها
على هذه الحمله وتوجيهها بقى ودعم كل
الاجهزه الامنيه بكل المكونات والامكانات
من اجل تحقيق الاهداف اعتقد ان احنا نشاهد
اليوم
ما في شك العمل استباقي مهم التحضير قبل
اي عمليه مهم ارجو نقل تحياتي لكافه
الزملاء العاملين في الميدان وكذلك جهودهم
مقدره جهودهم ملموسه ما زلنا في بدايه
الحملة عمله مستمره الى ان تحقق ان شاء
الله كل
من البلاغات تعامل بكل سريه وبكل
احترافيه بحيث لا يلحق المبلغ اي مسائله
ونحافظ على سريه بياناته وعلى معلوماته
فما في شكل للاستفاده من المعلومه ومهم
مكافحه المخدرات ورجال مكافحه المخدرات
يحظون بدعم كامل من سمو سيدي ولي العهد
مثل ما سبق ان ذكرتكم الجهود اللي
شاهدناها في الايام القليله الماضيه منهم
ومن زملائه في القطاعات الامنيه جهود
مميزه وان شاء الله نحقق كل اهداف ان شاء
الله المرجوه بدعم وتوجيهات ومتابعه
وللعهد اللي في الحقيقه يتابعوا الجهود
بشكل لحظي
والحمد لله الامور ماشيه في الطريق الصحيح
وان شاء الله تكلل كل الجهود بالنجاح
انضم الينا من الرياض مدير البرامج
العلاجيه في مركز رشد التخصصي للارشاد
الاسري والنفسي وعلاج الادمان حمد الشحات
حياك الله يا استاذ حمد الله في كل
المنازل اليوم الحديث الاول هو حمله
مكافحه المخدرات في الشوارع تجد ترى مظاهر
مختلفه تماما نحن امام حمله هي اشباب
الحرب ربما اذا جاز لنا وصفها بهذا
التعبير على المخدرات ترتيبات قرارات
صلاحيات واجراءات غير مسبوقه ابدا كمتابع
انت او متخصص في هذا اول شيء كيف شايف
نتائجها حتى الانوال الحمله كما قال سمو
وزير الداخليه قبل قليل لا زالت في
بدايتها
الحمد لله نسمع الخبر من لا زالت في
بدايتها الموضوع يحتاج وقت اثار الحمله
الان الحمد لله يعني الاقبال على العلاج
اصبح مضاعف يعني الاعداد عندنا كظائفه
اكثر من ضعفين في الاقبال على طلب الحلول
من خلال العلاج انا بعطيكم معلومه حلوه
مره يعني اول مره تطلع بالاعلام وبتكون
يعني العربيه يعني حصريا في هذه المعلومه
كان الاقبال من الشباب على الشابات على
العلاج يمثل 10% من يعني عدد المراجعين
اليوم تجاوزنا 60% يعني
للعلاج تجاوزوا 60% ولله الحمد كيف تتم
العمليه هذه
الان مادتين منتشره يعني بشكل يعني
يعني ملحوظ اللي هي ماده الشبو وماده
الملكه اللي هي الجبل اللي هي تستخدم لبعض
العلاجات الدوائيه يساعد استخدامها في
محظوره مقيده من اكثر من سنه
فهذه المادتين هي الاكثر الان في السوق
يعني في التعاقب نتكلم عن نسبه معينه انت
من خلال متابعتك
في مقابل مثلا الحشيش الحبوب وغيرها من
الامور
والله الحشيش ممكن ايضا نسبه عاليه في
التعاطي لكن انا اقول انتشار المادتين
اللي ذكرتها كان ملحوظ في الفتره الاخيره
لكن المتصدر دائما في التعافي هو الحشيش
يعني اعتقاد البعض ان الحشيش يعني ماده
ممكن يتعاطى الواحد ويعيش حياته بسلام
بما ان الحقيقه ان الحشيش يعني دمار على
المدى الطويل يعني يدمر الحياه ويعطل
الحياه بشكل يعني ملحوظ
الكثير من الحملات اللي تبنتها المملكه في
سنوات سابقه على المخدرات اكيد فرق بين
الحمله هذه اللي دفعت الناس اليوم الى
مثلا قلت كما قلت انه اصبحت العيادات زادت
الدرجه 60% من الشباب ليعاني من ندمان على
المخدرات
انفسهم لطلب الاعلام اما زياده بالنسبه
للاعداد اكثر من 60% يعني
النسب
تتزايد من الشباب انفسهم
يعني هم الان اقبلوا بسبب الحمله المباركه
الشباب نفسه يعني هذه الحمله اليوم مقارنه
بالحملات السابقه ليش نتوقع منها نتائج
مختلفه والى متى ممكن تستمر ترى مثلا انت
خبير في هذا المجال وشو الهدف النهائي لها
وهل يمكن تحقيقه لا سريعه
الهدف النهائي لها هو مثل ملك العارف
تنظيف البلد من السموم هذه من الاجرام
اللي صاير من التعاطي من الالم من الهم
والوهم اللي يعيش يا غالبيه شبابنا انت
اذا بغيت تدمر الشعب دمر شبابه واليوم
شبابنا قاعد يتدمر بالمخدرات والدوله
رعاها الله وحفظها التفتت للموضوع التفاته
حازمه والتفاته يعني صراحه تضرب باليوم
الدوله بيد من حديد على اي انسان تسوي له
نفسه انه يتلاعب او يعني يخدش قوه يعني
هالبلد واللي يقصد بالقوه اللي هي شباب
البلد الشابات البلد الله يحفظ الجميع
اليوم اذا شباب نتدمر تدمر البلد بالكامل
والحمد لله عندنا عندنا قياده شابه واعيه
الله يعطيهم العافيه على هال الحمله
المباركه شكرا لك مدير البرامج العلاجيه
في مركز رشدي التخصصي للارشاد الاسري
والنفسي وعلاج الاد مان حمد الشيحان
في الرابعه بعد قليل
منظمتنا امريكيه تصنف الكويت في المرتبه
الثانيه عالميا في نسبه الاصابه بمرض
السكري
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد ايام قليله
والتحديدا يوم الاحد المقبل تشهد السعوديه
يتلقى برنامج التاهيل المرشدين المهنيين
بتعاون المشترك بين صندوق الموارد البشريه
وجامعه الملك سعود يهدفوا برنامج وتاهيل
المرشدين لتحسين وتطوير الكفاءات السعوديه
في القطاع التعليمي والمساهمات في توظيف
الكوادر الوطنيه في مجال الاعمال في شتى
التخصصات وفي جميع المناطق
المبادره الاولى لتاهيل المرشدين في
المملكه هي احد مبادرات صندوق تنميه
الوارد البشريه واللي من خلالها يتم تدريب
وتاهيل عدد من المرشدين المهنيين في
القطاع العام والقطاع الخاص ايضا في
القطاعات التعليميه والقطاعات المهنيه
وهذا بلا شك احد الادوار اللي يقوم فيها
الصندوق من خلال دوره القيادي والقيادي في
مجال الارشاد المهني والهدف هو تعزيز
المحتوى المحلي في الارشاد المهني في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه من خلال الشراكه
مع جامعه الملك سعود من خلال انشاء شهادات
احترافيه ودراجات علميه في الارشاد المهني
لاول مره طبعا الارشاد المهني يعتبر ركيزه
اساسيه في كل العمليات عمليات التوظيف
والعمليات البحث عن الوظائف فلذلك كان
هناك حاجه ضروريه لان يكون هذا المشروع
يستهدف خريجي المدارس وخريجي الجامعات
فكان هناك شراكه بين جامعه الملك سعود
وصندوق الموارد البشريه
لبناء كوادر وطنيه مؤهله تساعد في تاهيل
ايضا المرشدين المهنيين وهذه ستكون باذن
الله باكوره المشروع الاول في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وباذن الله نستهدف ان
يكون هناك لدينا 820
مرشد مهني يكونون في جميع القطاعات
التعليم العام والتعليم العالي وقطاع
الاعمال
والى مكه المكرمه حيث بدات وزاره الداخليه
السعوديه بالامس تطبيق تنظيمات حج هذا
العام التي تقتضي منع اي مقيم لا يحمل
تصريحا من الدخول ويستثنى من المنعمه
لديهم تصريح دخول للعمل في المشاعر
المقدسه صادر من الجهه المختصه او هويه
مقيم صادره من العاصمه المقدسه او تصريح
عمره او تصريح حج
المركز ضبط الامني في الشميسي معنى مراسل
العربيه سلطان السلمي سلطان مرحبا بك كيف
يتم العمل الان على تنفيذ هذا القرار
اهلا بك خالد اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل من امام مركز الضبط الامني
بالشميسي وهو يعد من اكبر المنافذ المؤديه
الى العاصمه المقدسه نتحدث عن سبعه مراكز
او سبعه مراكز ضبط امني على كافه منافذ
مكه التي تؤدي للدخول الى العاصمه المقدسه
قامت امن الطرق السعوديه
بنشر تعليمات واضحه ودقيقه فيما يتعلق
بمنع دخول كافه المقيمين الى العاصمه
المقدسه لثلاث حالات فقط وهي لمن يملك
تسريع عمره
عفوا او تصريح حج او هويه مقيم صادره من
العاصمه المقدسه هذا القرار بدا يوم امس
الاثنين تحديدا في خوم الخامس والعشرين من
شهر 10 لهذا العام وسوف يستمر حتى
انتهاء موسم حجر هذا العام وياتي هذه
القرارات في كل عام في مثل هذا التوقيت
للحد من وجود حجاج مخالفين داخل العاصمه
المقدسه نتحدث فيما يتعلق بالمواطنين
السعوديين حتى المواطن السعودي لا يستطيع
الدخول الى مكه المكرمه في حال كان في حال
كان لابس لبس الاحرام او معتمر الا بتطبيق
نسك فقط فيما يتعلق بالمقيمين الساكنين
والقاتنين في مكه المكرمه يستطيعون الخروج
من مكه بشكل سلس بشرط ان يكون حامل هويه
هويه مقيم الصادره من العاصمه المقدس فيما
يتعلق بالمقيمين الراقدين من جده
والراغبين بالدخول الى العاصمه المقدسه
لاداء العمره يشترط ان يكون هنالك تصريح
من تطبيق بدات امن الطرق بعد عملها
والتاكد من كافه الهويات والتصاريح
المتعلقه بهؤلاء المقيمين كما نشاهد الان
في امامكم يقوم رجل الامن باخذ الهويات
والتاكد من التصاريح والهويات فيما يتعلق
بذلك في حال وجود مخالفين يتم اخذ بيانات
السائق والافراد الذين هم من هم على او من
هم في متن السوا على متر او داخل السياره
من ثم يتم اعادتهم بشكل طبيعي الى مدينه
جده حتى يمكننا تصريح لهم للعمره او تصريح
اقامه بمدينه بمكه المكرمه او حتى هويه
خاصه او تصريع عمل داخل المشاعر المقدسه
كل هذه الانظمه تجري تجري الان في كافه
المنافذ السبعه الرئيسيه من ضمنها الشميسي
وكذلك منفذ النواريه والكعكيه وغيرها من
منافذ داخل العاصمه المقدسه ايضا هناك
تجديد كبير من قبل هؤلاء الرجال للتاكد من
كافه الهويات وسلامتها فيما يتعلق
بالحافلات الضخمه هنالك مسارات مخصصه لهم
ايضا وجود مراء كاميرات مراقبه امنيه
للرسل ايضا وجود نقاط فرز متعدده هذه
النقطه الاولى ايضا هنالك نقاط اخرى في في
المقدمه للتاكد من كافه اوراق الثبوتيه
الخاصه بهؤلاء المقيمين كما نشاهد الان
يتم تحويل هذه السيارات الى مسارات اخرى
ومن ثم يتم ارجاعهم في حال وجود او عدم
وجود تصريح او هويه مقيم صادره من مكه
المكرمه شكرا لك سلطان السلمي من مركز
الضبط الامني في الشميسي
تصدرت الكويت المركز الثاني عالميا في
نسبه الاصابه بمرض السكري بعد باكستان
بحسب منظمه
الامريكيه ينتشر المرض في الكويت بنسبه
تقترب من 25% بسبب سوء التغذيه ونمط
الحياه اليوميه بحسب مختصين السمنه هي
السبب الرئيسي للاصابه بالمرض التي وضعت
ايضا الكويت في المركز التاسع عالميا بعد
انتشارها في البلاد بنسبه 38%
في الرابعه بعد قليل
الهلال يلتقي الاتحاد في قمه الجوله
السابعه والعشرين خطوه تقرب العميد من
الذهب والعالميه
ملك الاردن يعبر عن ثقته بنجاح قيمه جدا
ويصف النهضه السعوديه الحاليه بالملهمه
لدول المنطقه
شراب على هذه الحمله وتوجيه اباء ودعم كل
الاجهزه الامنيه وزير الداخليه السعوديه
واكدوا الدعم الكامل لمنسوبي مكافحه
المخدرات الحمله الحاليه لا تزال في
بدايتها
تنظيمات الحجم منع المقيمين من دخول مكه
دون تصريح او هويه مصدرها العاصمه المقدسه
شديد
سابق يصل قمه بعد تجاوزه
والموت يغيب الفنان الكوميدي السعودي فهد
الحيان عن 52 عاما طاش ما طاش ابرز محطته
الفنيه
اهلا بكم دشنت الهيئه السعوديه للبيانات
والذكاء الاصطناعي سدايا اليوم مركز
التميز للذكاء الاصطناعي التوليدي
بالتعاون مع الشركه التقنيه العالميه
انفيديا خلال الملتقى اطلاق اطلاق النسخه
التجريبيه لتطبيق علام الذي يعتبر اول
تطبيق محادثه باللغه العربيه في السعوديه
هذا التطبيق يقوم بمحادثه المستخدمين
والرد على استفساراتهم باللغه العربيه
الفصحى وكذلك بالعاميه
رياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نصفيان
مرحبا بك كيف تتم التجربه
خلينا نشوف معك على الهواء اهلا بك خالد
طبعا سنتحدث اولا عن هذا المركز وتحديدا
في هذا الوقت وهو مركز التميز الذكاء
الاصطناعي التوليدي وهو التابع الهيئه
السعوديه للبينات ولذكاء الاصطناعي سدايا
طبعا هذا المركز تم تدشينه اليوم اضافه
الى اطلاق برنامج علام وكذلك ايضا هناك
مبادره تهدف الى تدريب اكثر من اربعه 4000
شخص لكن
ساتحدث ايضا عن هذا التطبيق والذي يعتبر
الاول على مستوى المنطقه الذي يطلق في من
خلال خصائصه كالاجابه والرد على استفسارات
من يرغب بالبحث عن معلومه بشكل متزن ودقيق
عموما الدكتور ماجد التويجري وهو المشرف
عام على مركز اعمال الذكاء الاصطناعي هنا
في سداي مرحبا بك الدكتور يعني اليوم
عندنا
السعوديين كفاء باحثين مهندسين في الذكاء
الاصطناعي هذا على سبيل المثال منتج قبل
ما نتكلم هذا هو تطبيق علام صحيح ما هو
الفرق بين هذا التطبيق علام وبين ايضا
تطبيقات الاخرى لنشاهدها نعم اولا
اللغه العربيه في التطبيقات الحاليه
التجاريه الموجوده الان ضعيف جدا يعني
الان اللغه العربيه تمثل تقريبا اقل من
خمسه على الف من اللغات الاخرى بالتالي
مصداقيه اللغه العربيه تكون ضعيفه ايضا
تمثيل التاريخ السعودي تمثيل الحضاره
تمثيل الثقافه ضعيف جدا ايضا في امور تخص
الدين وتخص اشياء وهذا بالنسبه لنا هويه
اللغه العربيه هويه واحنا في سدايا عملنا
خطه استراتيجيه لتقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي
التوليدي باللغه العربيه رفعت لمجلس
الاداره وحصلت على دعم كبير من قبل مجلس
الاداره برئاسه سمو ولي العهد رئيس مجلس
اداره سدايا ومنذ ذلك اليوم احنا نعمل على
تطوير هذه المنتجات اللي تواكب المنتجات
العالميه انا بسوي سيرش يا دكتور معاك
واسوي عمليه بحث ابي اكتب قناه العربيه
وبشوف يعني التفاصيل اللي راح يطلعن قناه
العربيه هل هي بالفعل صحيحه وهي فتره
تجريبيه طبعا هذا نعم انا ودي اوضح انه في
بعض الاسئله لو تشوف مثلا من هو وزير
الصحه في المملكه تلقى لنا المعلومه جديده
الان جانا
الردة باللغه العربيه يعني واضح فيها
معلومات وفعلا يعني لو القارئ او من يعرف
هذه المعلومات فعلا هي معلومات دقيقه
وواضحه نعم هذه المعلومه عشان تصل بالشكل
هذا هو يبحث من مئات الملايين من قواعد
البيانات الين يحصل على منتج او او رد
بالشكل هذا طبعا
[موسيقى]
انا خالد
لا لا لا
نصفين
كتبت خالد
خالد مدخلي وخليني اشوف يتعرف عليك يعني
ما حد عرفك على الطبيعه
ههه
طبعا اسماء متشابهه هذا واحد ثاني
هو طبعا يجب انك تعرف كيف تتعامل مع طريقه
السؤال وطريقه هذه
وانت تسولف خلينا نشوف النتيجه
ان شاء الله انا جالس اكتب من هو مراسل
العربيه لا لا اكتب هاي
الحركات
لازم اكتب انه لا انه لازم تكتبوا شيء
توضيحي يعني
دكتور كان يمكن ودي انا اوضح شيء واحد هذا
المنتج يا ولد يعني المعلومه الحمد لله
صحيحه
لا مختلفه غطه مجموعه واسعه من الموضوعات
والقضايا سمعتي خالد عرفتك طبعا المنتج
اللي تشوفونه امامكم يقبل الكلام بالصوت
باللهجه العاميه لهجات سعوديه ايضا لهجه
مصريه ويمنيه فممكن تتكلم بلهجتك ممكن
تسولف معاه وتقول لي اعيد لي الكلام اللي
قلته بشكل عربي مرتب هذه كلها من ضمن
الخصائص اللي عملها كل هذه الخصائص يا
دكتور الان يعني شاهد برضو ان هناك في في
هذا
نعم الله يحفظك عندك ممكن تعطيه وثيقه
باللغه العربيه ترجمها للانجليزي والفرنسي
ممكن تعطيه وثيقه ويلخصها ممكن يلون
والتلوين يمكن نشوفه
بالشاشه الثانيه
اللي يميز ان التلوين يعرف الالوان
الالوان يعني اعرف ان الشماغ لونه احمر
ويعرف ان البشت المقصب فيه لون ذهبي وهذي
لن تجدها في الانظمه الثانيه شكرا لك يا
دكتور ماجد اذا هذا هو تطبيق علامي يعطيك
العافيه دكتور ماجد تعرفه او عرف لنا عن
هذا التطبيق اعلام وكذلك الان نتحدث من
خلال هنا مركز التميز الذكاء الاصطناعي
التوليدي سدايا وهذا التطبيق الان هو في
مرحله تجريبيه وايضا سوف يكون في المرحله
المقبله
بين ايادي المستفيدين سواء داخل السعوديه
او خارجها شكرا لك
واضح انت معروف في كل مكان يعني لا بس
لحاله
انا عمري انها 52 عام توفي الفنان السعودي
فهد الحيان بعد اصابته بازمه قلبيه مفاجاه
الحقيقه كان رمزا من رموز الكوميديا
السعوديه مسلسل طاش اول تجربه الانتاجيه
واحد ابرز اعمالي مسلسل غشمشه الذي ادى
بطولته منذ عام 2006
رحل هزار وانتهى مشوار فني بدا في العام
للفنان السعودي فهد الحيان الذي وافته
المنيه اذى سكته قلبيه مساء الاحد
[موسيقى]
كان مسلسل طاش ما طاش بدايه انطلاقته
لمشواره الفني وعرفه الجمهور من خلال عدد
من الشخصيات الكوميديه اشهرها ازار التي
احبها الصغير والكبير ليبدا بعدها بحصد
النجوميه ويشارك في عدد من الاعمال وعلى
سبيل المثال من الحصر خلك معي ابو
العصافير وهشتقه ومسلسل منه فينا
وفي العام 2006 انتج مسلسل غشمشم الذي حظي
فيه بدور البطوله وامتد لسته مواسم ابوي
اقول لامك تصلح قهوه
تبي تصرفني
[موسيقى]
ولا تركيش
مسيره فنيه حافله وسخت في ذاكره الجماهيره
بشخصيات متعدده اشهرها هازار ورويشد
وغشمشم ارتفعت بعد وفاته الدعوات وتزاحم
التعازي الوسط الفني في الوطن العربي كافه
لتعزيه ذوي الفنان فهد الحيان الذي ترك
ارثا فنيا خالدا في الاذهان
من رياض محمد خالد العربيه
اصبح اكبر عربي يصل الى قمه ايفرست
عبدالله القويس الدبلوماسيه السعوديه
السابق احد اشهر ممارسي الهايكينج وصل الى
القمه رغم تجاوزه 84 عاما نتابع بعضا من
مشاهد التي وثقها الغويز اثناء طريقه الى
قمه ايفرست
[موسيقى]
حاولنا يكون معنا الدكتور عبد الله القويس
في لقاء مباشر من جبل فلسطين يمكن لكن
الاتصال لم نستطيع ذلك نحاول نشوف نقدر
خلينا نشوف الان اذا كان يطلع معنا
الدكتور عبدالله دكتور عبد الله
هلا يا مرحبا يا دكتور حياك الله الحمد
لله على السلامه نقول
الله يسلمك ويطول عمرك طمني عليك وين وصلت
ممتاز
ممتاز وين وصلت قبل 30 دقيقه تقول انك
وصلت
مخيم بيسكام
كامل
يبلغ ارتفاعه
بحدود 5400 ما شاء الله تبارك الله كيف
كيف التجربه دكتور عبد الله
وين الصعوبه مقارنه بكلمنجارو
دكتور تسمعني
وين الصعوبه مقارنه وبين كلمنجاره
والتجربه
اطول
اطول ايفرست بصعوبه بس في اليوم الاخير
لكن هذا يعني من تقريبا اليوم الثاني يبدا
عندك
والبرد برد الشديد
لكن المناظر جميله للغايه
وما ممكن تشوفوا
الظواهر الطبيعيه الا في هذا المكان من
الوديان اللي فيها المياه واحيانا مغطاه
الى ان ترتفع الى مستوى معين 3000 3,500
تبدا الاشجار
وبعدين تختفي
الاخيره دكتور انت بتكتفي بهذا الارتفاع
ولا ناوي تكمل وين توصل
اللقاء
تصل الى نقطه التي ينطلق منها المحترفون
الذين يصلون الى القمه
انت ناوي توصل
من الناس اللي وصلوا اليه وصل لها خمسه
سعوديين
وامراتين
انت انت الان في اي مرحله من من رحلتك
دكتور
لا
خلاص
هذه النهايه
والشعرت فيه دكتور عبد الله لما وصلتي
لهذا المكان الى هذه القمه في هذا
الارتفاع لانه
وما كانوا يتوقع انه انه
في هذا السن لكن الحمد لله
هو اول سعودي وصل الى القمه الكبير
وكيف استطاعت تتكيف مع كل التحديات
والعوائق والبرد الشديد دكتور وانت في
هالسن
يا اخي
هنروح انا وانت ان شاء الله رحله جايه
اسمعك يا خالد اقول ودي اروح معك الرحله
الجايه ان قدرت
الله يحييك الله يحييك الرحله الجايه ان
شاء الله الشهر الجاي
ما شاء الله عليك الشهر الجاي على طول يا
دكتور طيب اصبر ارتاح شوي يعني
دكتور انت بس تبغى تقول بعد ما وصلت انه
انا اكبر سعودي وعربي وصل لهذه القمه هذا
هو هذه الرساله وهذا الانجاز اللي تبغى
توصل له ولا في اهداف لا لا
لا
بس الواحد يعني
يحرك
ويبتعد عن الخمول
وحاول يشوف ثقافات جديده واماكن جديده
مختلفه
يعني شوف الثقافات الشعوب يعني اللي شفته
في هذه الديره اشياء غريبه يعني
ناحيه ثانيه
يبدو انه هذه صايره موضح حكايه
فوجدت افواج من الناس تقريبا 70 80%
يبدو انها صايره يعني موضه
يمكن بعد الكورونا يعني
لكن التجربه تستحق صراحه التجربه هذه كمان
تستحق لقاء مطول لانه تجربه مختلفه واكيد
يعني احنا موعودين ان شاء الله انه نقف
على كل تفاصيلها
وصولا ان شاء الله حتى وصولك الى الى
المملكه كل التوفيق لك دكتور ونزول امن
وسهله لك ومبروك مبروك هذا الانجاز وهذا
النجاح اللي مثلنا جميعا والله يا دكتور
يعطيك الف عافيه
شكرا
ملك الاردن يعبر عن ثقته بنجاحكمه الجده
ويصف النهضه السعوديه الحاليه بالملهمه
لدول المنطقه
وزير الداخليه السعوديه واكدوا الدعم
الكامل لمنسوبيه مكافحه المخدرات الحمل
الحاليه لا تزال في بدايتها
بدات تنظيمات الحج منع المقيمين من دخول
مكه دون تصريح نوويه مصدرها العاصمه
المقدس
عبد الله القويس دبلوماسيون مصرفي سعوديه
سابق يصل قمه بعد تجاوز 84 عاما
والموت يغيب الفنان الكوميدي السعودي فهد
الحيان عن 52 عاما ابرز محطاته الفنيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات